this video was made possible by class
central.com
/ Pakman where you can go to watch
college lectures on thousands of
fascinating topics check it out by
clicking the link underneath this video
numerology is an umbrella of belief
systems which claims that numbers in and
of themselves can have divine or even
supernatural properties numerology has
many forms a numerologist might say
there are numbers that are universally
lucky or important or they might say
that the numbers in someone's date of
birth have special meaning for that
person numerologists often say that the
letters of the alphabet have
corresponding numbers so we can convert
the names of people and things into
numbers and derive meaning from that
numerology has manifested in many ways
in many cultures for thousands of years
and the most common type today is what's
called Pythagorean numerology and it's
debated whether this was actually
devised by ancient Greek philosopher and
mystic pythagoras some historians say
it's more likely it was developed by his
followers in the centuries after his
death known as the pythagoreans who
posited that the numbers 1 through 10
each hold a special meaning they said
the number 1 represents the origin of
all things the number 2 represents
physical matter and the number 3
symbolizes a story because they said it
encompassed a beginning middle and end
they considered odd numbers masculine
and even numbers feminine and they
believed that the number 5 was a symbol
for marriage because it was the sum of 2
& 3 the number 10 was the most sacred of
all called the perfect number and many
pythagoreans even refused to meet in
groups larger than 10 out of respect for
the number 10 a triangle made of 10 dots
was the symbol for their movement there
are many types of numerological methods
today which claim to be rooted or
inspired by Pythagorean numerology and
one of the most popular practices today
is assigning all the letters of the
alphabet a number one through nine and
deriving the numbers that are in your
name then calculating those numbers in
various ways until you end up with one
final number or a set of numbers which
supposedly have special meaning and tell
you something about your personality or
your future or your life another
convention is to use an upside-down
triangle to add up the digits of your
birthday and then continue to calculate
the numbers in other frivolous ways
until you have one number which
supposedly has special meaning and can
give you insight about your life here's
another process used to derive meaning
from your birthday okay so we have
February 28 1954 so February is - it's
the second month we have 28 and we have
1954 so how numerology works is you keep
adding together so - that's just one
digit 28 is two plus eight - one plus
nine plus five plus four what is that
equal one plus 9 is 10 plus 5 is 15 plus
4 is 19 19 and then we keep adding again
and then okay and then we keep adding
for the final time we've got two we've
got one one plus zero what's that one
one excellent so now we have a final
three numbers okay four so now we have
discovered lose life number his birth
date number and that is four there's
never one set way to perform these
calculations and different numerologists
say they know the true and accurate way
to do it but there are limitless ways of
matching letters with numbers of
calculating them and of course of
assigning the resulting numbers meaning
and this is an important whole in
numerology not only is it questionable
to arbitrarily attribute meaning to the
different numbers and letters that do
the calculations there are so many
different ways of doing it that you
can't possibly sort out what the right
method is for the calculations
themselves how would we even go about
assessing
the merit of each method here's another
big problem with numerology think about
the idea of numbers at a fundamental
level almost everywhere today we use a
numeral system that's known as base 10
meaning when we count 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 and so on the pattern of 10
repeats every time we get to 10 we're
sort of starting over at one with 11 or
21 or 31 but no matter how high we count
we're really only working with 10
numbers or digits 0 through 9 at first
it might seem like the number system we
use is inherent to mathematics but it's
not the fact that we have ten numbers
repeating is arbitrary we could just as
easily use a numeral system based on the
number eight in which only the numbers 0
through 7 are used which would look like
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17
etcetera 10 in base 8 would be equal to
8 in base 10 11 in base 8 would be equal
to 9 in base 10 and so on there are
regions in Papua New Guinea for example
that use a base 27 numeral system where
they have 27 number symbols which repeat
the people of us ood are so island in
Indonesia use of base 6 system for
example and the ancient Babylonians had
a system with 60 repeating numerals but
many ancient civilizations like the
Hebrews the Armenians Chinese the Greeks
they all independently use the base 10
numeral system and anthropologists
believe this is probably because we have
10 fingers humans regardless of what
culture they belong to would express
numbers using fingers and when they got
to 10 and ran out of fingers they had to
start over so the point here is there's
nothing mathematically special about the
number 10 or even of a base 10 numeral
system and this discredits numerology
even more because almost all types of
numerology are based on the base 10
numeral system a numerologist might say
the numbers 3 and 13 have the same
meaning because they're both versions of
the number 3 but that's only the case in
a base 10 system in other system
that aren't base-10 three and thirteen
wouldn't have that relationship
numerology also assumes that there's
something special about how we think
about dates but dates and calendars much
like the numeral systems are also in
large part arbitrary inventions by
humans yeah the earth rotates about 365
times over the course of one revolution
around the Sun and it takes about one
month for the moon to orbit the earth
but it doesn't line up exactly which is
why we have leap years it's why full
moons occur on a different day each
month nothing in physical reality tells
us what the current year is or that the
first month of the year occurs at a
certain point in Earth's orbit around
the Sun the year 2018 the concept of
January they only exist because we say
they exist the calendar that we use the
Gregorian calendar which is the only
thing establishing that one AD was 2017
years ago is totally made up it was
introduced in 1582 and it only exists in
people's minds many different calendars
have been used throughout human history
why does numerology happen to conform to
this particular calendar here's another
example a numerologist might say that
the time of day 11:11 whether it's a.m.
or p.m. has special significance they
might claim that notable events linked
to 11:11 occur more often than would be
explained by mere probability or chance
or many numerologists say that
accidentally glancing at a clock when
the time is 11:11 brings you good luck
numerology says that the time 11:11 is
important because quote 11 symbolizes
the potential to push the limitations of
the human experience into the
stratosphere of the highest spiritual
perception the link between the mortal
and the immortal between man and spirit
between darkness and light ignorant and
enlightenment so we run into another
problem here which you can probably
figure out by now the 24-hour day is
made by humans as well first the
Egyptians who divided their Sun
miles into 24 parts the day is also not
exactly 24 hours long and how we adjust
for this is also a human invention the
60-minute hour the 62nd minute no
relationship to objective reality it
came from the Babylonians and like I
mentioned the Babylonian number system
in general was based on 60 and it's also
how they kept track of time hours
minutes seconds these are all man-made
concepts just like calendars and generic
numeral systems so can we assign meaning
to these numbers and expect it to
correspond with anything that's
happening in the real world in the end
it might be useless to try to explain
this logic to a numerologist because
most numerological claims are mystic or
supernatural and logic doesn't really
apply in that domain numerology is just
another belief system and methodology
whose validity is totally unfalsifiable
it relies on superstition and
attributing meaning to coincidences
numbers are one of the most important
tools of abstraction and abstract
thinking that humans have which gives
numerology a facade of being reasonable
or intellectual math is pure and it's
elegant and it's powerful which is
probably why numerologists are so
tempted to do what they do but to
subscribe to numerology is to entirely
misunderstand what numbers are
metaphysically numbers are just ideas if
we're looking at a room with four chairs
in it the number four doesn't exist in
the room four is a way of thinking about
the chairs numbers can't exist in the
real world much less are they able to
have causal relationships with events in
the real world and that's fundamentally
why numerology fails to add up if you
want to delve deeper into the
philosophical foundations of math check
out a free course from Stanford
University called introduction to
mathematical thinking you can search for
it at class
- central.com forward slash pakman class
central lets you take entire college
courses online from top you
universities whether you're interested
in science politics philosophy
psychology there are tens of thousands
of courses to choose from so you're
bound to find something you're into
check it out at class
- central.com forward slash Pakman